What's up everybody!
Welcome to another episode of
Challenge Pongfinity
This is the series where YOU
Challenge US
With your craziest ideas
Related to table tennis.
If your comment gets picked
We will feature it in our next video
And give you a shout out.
So make sure you leave your comments
In the comment-section below!
Man of Matt wants us to play with a detached
net.
Not sure if this is going to work out
But let's try!
Alright, next we will play on 3 tables.
We have a made triangle out of them.
Let's try and play on them!
Matias Kuhs wants us to play with a bouncy
ball
Instead of a table tennis ball.
Only 1 meter over the table!
Thanks for watching guys
Hope you enjoyed this episode!
If you liked it, leave a thumbs up.
Subscribe here
And watch our previous episodes here.
Until next time!